one of the more controversial Superbowl  ads featured a young girl in a soapbox  derby race and the ad dealt with issues  like women's rights equal pay gender  disparity and I will say I understand  the controversy of the ad if you didn't  check it out take a look what do I tell  my daughter  do I tell her that her grandpa's worth  more than her grandma  [Music]  that her dad is worth more than her mom  [Music]  do I tell her there despite her  education or drive her skills her  intelligence  she will automatically be valued as less  than every man she ever meets yes  absolutely  I gotta say I didn't see that coming  came outta left field  you